senator lindsey graham he is the ranking
republican on the senate budget
committee and senator it's always a
pleasure to see you thank you for being
here
can you take us behind the doors
yesterday when this bill passed and what
is in it
yeah well number one it took 27 hours to
pass it i'm proud of my republican
colleagues for fighting back but
what a difference a year makes maria
march of 2020
we passed a 1.9 trillion dollar bill the
same amount of money
96 to nothing because we understood the
need to fight covet a year later march
of 2021
the democrats have the house descended
in the white house and what did we tell
you
if they get everything they're going to
run us over this is out of control
liberalism and in this bill as uh kevin
said
most of the money is not spent this year
90 percent of it's got nothing to do
with covet but let me give you an
example
of something that really bothers me in
this bill if you're a farmer
your loan will be forgiven up to 120
percent of your loan
not a hundred percent but 120 of your
loan
if you're socially disadvantaged if
you're african-american
some other minority but if you're white
person if you're a white woman no
forgiveness
that's reparations what has that got to
do with covet
so if you're in the farming business
right now this bill forgives
120 of you alone based on your race
these people in the congress today the
house and the senate on the democratic
side
are out of control liberals and uh god
help us all
if we don't check and balance them in
2022.
this is just incredible and we're
looking at the list of things
that money is uh being allocated toward
you know
300 million dollars toward the arts and
humanities i mean
where is this money coming from now that
we've got a 28 trillion dollar tab in
debt
well it's coming from your children your
grandchildren it's all borrowed money
there's 200 million dollars for library
services there's uh
over 300 million dollars for the
national endowment of the humanities and
arts
there's 20 million dollars for native
language studies
these all may be good ideas but they got
nothing to do
with covid